so can I ask this question do you
regular masturbate
you cannot say question you're not going
to answer hey hello hey aunty and that
and I'm Victoria nice to meet you
Victoria has interested I'm a priest in
the Church of England nuts oh why do
this
oh wow okay and you so I feel like it's
the reductionist thing why don't you
tell me why you think why you strongly
disagree I'm gonna sit on this line
that's okay with you well obviously this
there's some people that are forced into
it she'll pay that is completely wrong
but if somebody is happily doing that
why is it wrong how many people go on
diets that is 90 percent of the
population yeah sure
have you been on kansai expose yeah well
you know I'm a person as well you aren't
yet I think the the mass adoption of
porn is what makes it really dangerous
I don't think porn exploits people I
think people exploit people and I think
some people within the porn industry
probably are exploiting people it is a
largely unregulated and and I think much
of porn is openly misogynistic
heteronormative I definitely want to say
it's it's it's objectifying it's very
worst it can encourage all kind of rape
culture if we're gonna have porn if it's
gonna be a big regulator and we need a
higher quality porn we need higher
quality form that should be porn or high
quality regulated and higher quality
form which shows people how to respect
she won't not more than of insiders and
we need we need to but there is that out
there sure yeah I've got very glad to
hear go ahead girl why do you agree well
I mean so I'm not wearing a dog collar
they're not a particular part of the
church in my tradition we don't wear dog
collars very often okay and but if I
were the type of things that people show
you in the street are things like
pedophile really yeah I mean there's
been so much in the media about priests
yeah who have abused their position yeah
and and religion has abused its position
so often in the history of mankind I
didn't think you'd actually get up used
to be honest yeah well I say so
meanwhile other I really didn't think
that you would get abused if you had a
collar on quite a shock here but I get a
lot of sure you can in my chair sure
yeah tell me I'm from the school
teachers from my neighbors from the
police Eva and I won't even throw in the
police if there's an emergency if I can
deal with it myself but I just kind of
feel like well hmm she just that she's
bought it myself
yeah a lot of women don't want to accept
me as a friend because I think run off
with a boyfriend
that's horrible horrible to be so cast
onto the edge of society yeah do you
have any examples of kind of times that
you've received abuse I'll tell you this
one that sticks in mind used to do with
a church he's because I do the road
represent a member of the church had
printed off some indecent pictures of me
that they'd found online and handed them
round the the church and they don't want
me or my family part of the church the
vicar was lovely actually and he's
accepted me but you see there's many
people that don't want me in that
charity I'm sorry I'm sorry that anyone
in the church whatever and do that to
you
it's terrible also what was they doing
on them fat
a horrible way to go this should be
stopped everybody have a copy I mean I I
want a caveat my answer just to say I do
think sex finds its fulfillment in
long-term loving relationships and
marriage is a really good example of
that
why somebody doesn't want to get
marriage in the happy on the road what
they have that desire I do
I'd want to say that that's a symptom if
you feel happy on your own but you're
not that happy because you need to hook
up with your friend like there's
something within you which craves for
something more the reason that I think
that we should perhaps not do that it's
not because I'm like well hey everyone
stop having fun
I believe there's more fun to be had but
like the depths of getting to know
somebody alongside that intimate
relationship I think it's is probably
it's far better than I completely
understand that but what like what if
you go into a situation where there's
couples that enjoy having some gels and
there's sexual I guess everyone asked
why like what is it that in your own
limited missing that may be so and not
and I don't want to come across like
well thankfully I've got it sorted I
don't want no threesome because we all
have like this broken longing within us
you know I'm not sure that kind of
taking your marriage or your long your
partnership or whatever and saying like
let's bring someone else in they'll
solve it people are so busy now they've
got busy lives you know yeah spend that
much time out and stuff like that we
don't have much time to make those
relationships and sometimes we just
fulfill that needs yeah yeah totally we
I'm sympathetic to that through and
through I just don't know if that's
really living that you don't have time
to like build a solid foundation and
intimate relationship in your life I
don't have time to build a solid
intimate relationship apart from you
know just the children I don't have to
have that and I think that it's a poor
reflection on our society
[Music]
I'm surprised you disagreed why are you
surprised that an ended here I don't I I
just kind of seem judging okay yeah I
guess I've so it's pan so it's fine to
please yourself I guess you know
masturbation it's fine just what you're
looking at and is it okay to must be
looking at porn normal porn do you think
I mean it should that just be because
even me even if you masturbate in your
imagine him it's make-believe I I think
I'd want to go not really thinking is
that in the toilet haha it's an
imagination and we for feel like my
generation so I think I'd want to go
back to some of the arguments earlier
about some of the darker side upon what
it can it can be really misogynistic it
can objectify it does objectify this guy
becomes his [ __ ] this woman just becomes
a bunch of orifices we walk around and
that's how we can begin to see people if
you immerse yourself in that world
enough but that is a small percentage
and that could happen on many of
different subjects not just Paul no
totally totally which is why you know
which is why I think like it's probably
not as black and white
yeah as we've made it there are many
shades of grey there are 50 shades of
grey right there at least 50 shades of
grey can I ask this question do you
regular masturbate you cannot state
question you're not gonna answer I'm
gonna answer no I don't do you try not
to do you hold that urge off I do I got
little kids I'm too tired for that
alright okay okay so you are ridden like
how my regions like that yeah I mean get
the Catholic priests here who you know
has vowed to celibacy and we'll see what
he's got to say about it I assume do you
think well I don't know married yeah
sorry to disappoint
I consider my job a vocation like far
more than like a career I feel that it's
something I'm called to do I feel like I
couldn't do anything else this is this
is what I'm made for and in that sense I
love it
continue so I yeah strongly I love my
job I work for myself it means that I
can take charge in school I can always
pick the children back up I could always
put them in bad well 90% of the time and
it just it fits random and why not it's
my body if I feel comfortable enough to
do that yeah I really enjoy it I do
enjoy it and I couldn't see me doing
this until I retire it's really
interesting and your lovely person no
thank you this has been great
you know we do have the canines we do
have the incisors for ripping and
tearing there's some really interesting
information and studies that people have
found out there about our our early
ancestors and how eating meat and the
specific proteins for me actually made
us human as we are today I do often
wonder if vegans and maybe the
devolution of man like in 20 years maybe
maybe we're going to turn back into use
like the monkey saw you know